Speaker 1: All right, the big foreign policy
news overnight is that Joe Biden is going to
leave Afghanistan on the schedule he most
recently put in place, which is August
31st. And I have to tell you, foreign policy is
very complicated. Foreign policy typically has
ifs, ands and buts. But as many of you have
continued to email me about, some in agreement,
some in disagreement, this is one of the clearest
and most black white sort of decisive ways that
I've seen foreign policy carried out. And I
agree with it 100 percent. And we're going to
talk about why. But the big news is that indeed,
Joe Biden is confirming that the United States
will keep its August 31st deadline, saying
yesterday, the sooner we finish, the better.
Joe Biden said yesterday the U.S. is on track to
complete its hurried airlift in Afghanistan by
August 31st. Acknowledging he does not plan to
keep American troops in the country any longer,
even as questions remain over who will be able
to leave and when. In late afternoon remarks at
the White House, Biden recognized the success of
the mission will depend largely on cooperation
from the Taliban. He said he's asked military
leaders to be ready with contingency options
to adjust the timetable if it becomes necessary.
We are currently on pace to finish by August 31,
he said. I am determined to complete our
mission. This is completely the right decision
now on cost alone, looking at what has been spent
in Afghanistan over the last 20 years, leaving is
completely justified on failed policy alone,
meaning we aren't making any progress there.
And in fact, the longer we stay, we are merely
delaying the inevitable while spending more money
on failed policy alone. You could justify leaving
on the length of time we've been there alone.
You could even maybe justify leaving, meaning even
if you could justify the cost, which you can't,
even if you could make the case that you
were somehow succeeding, which we aren't.
Just the fact that it's been 20 years would in
some sense justify leaving. But it's all of these
things and more. And we have to be able to look at
it and say Barack Obama was wrong to stay there.
Donald Trump was wrong to stay there. Joe Biden
is right to leave. That's the big picture. And
the rest of it is details. Now, they are important
details. The details are important for sure. Like,
for example, did we adequately plan for getting
people out? And that includes Americans,
but that also includes what is happening from the
standpoint of refugees. Did we plan appropriately
for the humanitarian fallout and on and on. But
we have now evacuated more than 70000 people.
And here is Joe Biden explaining it.
Speaker 2: As of this afternoon, we've
helped evacuate seventy thousand seven hundred
people just since August of fourteen seventy
five thousand nine hundred people since the end of
July, just in the past 12 hours, another 19 U.S.
military flights, 18 C 17 and one C-130 carrying
approximately six thousand four hundred evacuees.
And thirty one coalition flights carrying five
thousand six hundred people have left Kabul
just in the last 12 hours. A total of 50 more
flights, 12000 more people since we updated you
this morning. These numbers are a testament to
the efforts of our brave service women and men
to our diplomats on the ground in Kabul
and to our allies still standing with us.
Speaker 1: And as I tweeted to much reaction
last night, Biden gets out of a 20 year quagmire
in Afghanistan, evacuates more than 70000 people.
And as of now, no Americans have died. And we're
supposed to believe that this is bad. And you've
seen Fox News say it's bad because, of course,
it's Biden. You've seen other media outlets
sometimes considered left, sometimes considered
centrist, sometimes merely just corporate media
outlets play up. Well, shouldn't we maintain a
presence? Shouldn't we stay, et cetera? No,
no. And this has really exposed the kind of
corporatist pro it's not even really pro-war.
It's just pro foreign intervention, status quo
or default position of so many of the media
outlets, even considered to be left by some.
So now we get to the details and of course, the
details are important. Afghanistan fell to the
Taliban in a weekend. Now, there are some who
are looking at that and are saying, well, that's
evidence that we didn't handle the withdrawal
appropriately. I would actually say the opposite.
I would say that if after 20 years Afghanistan
fell to the Taliban in a weekend, there was
nothing you could do to prevent that from
happening sooner or later if you left. And the
fact that it happened in a weekend is proof that
we should be out of there. We should have left
sooner, not stayed longer. So this is arguably the
best thing that Joe Biden has done. And you have
to really look at the motivations of the different
people that are criticizing the decision. There
are some on the left who are criticizing the
decision merely because they want to show their
progressive credentials and they want to criticize
Biden no matter what. That's some people.
Similarly, there are those on the right who are
ignoring the fact that Donald Trump had the exact
same plan. It would have been carried out in
the exact same way, no matter what he tells you.
And they are saying, well, no, no, no, Biden did
it wrong. Trump would have done it correctly.
They are obviously incorrect about that as well.
And then, of course, you have the fact that
so much of the media is saying, was this actually
right? Should we have stayed with Rababah?
That confirms, as I mentioned, this kind of status
quo, pro intervention bias. The issues now are
can we continue getting Americans out safely?
And how many Afghan lives can we also save? And
that has to be a priority as well. But if we
look at everything Joe Biden has done so far,
this is one of the major accomplishments. This has
been a 20 year quagmire started by George W. Bush.
We arguably never should have gone. If we did, we
should have left, what, 18, 17 years ago. I mean,
that's in the most generous point, the most
generous interpretation. And we can't fall for
the concern. Trolls, quite frankly, is what they
are on both sides. So if you want to email me and
say, well, this could have been better planned or
that could have been better planned, sure, I'll
probably agree with you. But this was a decisive
action by Joe Biden. It was the right decisive
action. And the idea that we should be criticizing
him for finally getting us out is really it's
it's depressing to see from how many different
sides. That's the perspective that we are seeing.